hello everyone welcome to the biggest
ideas in the universe I'm your host John
Carroll this is idea number 18 and we
are continuing to sort of build back up
the universe of our everyday experience
from these fundamental ideas that we've
been talking about so the ideas we've
been talking about so far often go under
the rubric of fundamental or elementary
physics and that doesn't mean
fundamental in the sense of more
important or more interesting or worth
more money or anything like that it just
means that the stuff we've been talking
about makes up the stuff of our everyday
life it's sensible to say that protons
and neutrons are made of quarks that
atoms are made of electrons and protons
and neutrons but it doesn't make sense
to say that protons and neutrons are
made of atoms that just wouldn't be true
so the fundamental physics we've been
talking about so far is sort of the base
level stuff and then you put it together
to make bigger things and it turns out
that in the process of making bigger
things a lot of incredibly cool stuff
happens it's not always personally my
area of expertise so I can't do it
justice as well as some other people
might but there are some very clear big
ideas worth talking about in that
journey back to our everyday world and
today's big idea is atoms now atoms
might sound a little down-to-earth you
might feel like well I know about atoms
I don't need to watch this one right you
might not know about the spin statistics
theorem or gauge Theory but you know
what the little picture with the protons
and the neutrons and all the electrons
going around it I'm using the catch-all
word atoms as usual to describe some
deeper things what I want to describe is
how you start with the rules of the
standard model of particle physics or
really the core theory that also has
gravity in it and how you end up with
the stuff that actually makes up you and
me why these particular atom so I'm not
necessarily telling you what an atom is
and expecting you be surprised I'm
explaining why atoms are that way so
where we really start is with the
standard model of particle physics and
I'm just gonna call it the standard
model even though including gravity for
reasons which we've already talked about
and you know that what's in the standard
model are fermions
which make up the matter particles okay
and fermions come in two different
classes there are quarks well it just
let my mind there for a minute
quarks quarks which are colored they
have red green or blue colors and
they're subject to the strong nuclear
force quantum chromodynamics pushing
around the colors and then leptons which
are just particles that are fermions and
do not feel the strong nuclear force
both the quarks and the leptons feel the
weak nuclear force they feel gravity
most of them feel electromagnetism and
so forth so you have the fermions and
then you have the bosons and the bosons
also come in two very different classes
they're the gauge bosons the sort of
traditional force carrying bosons for
the electromagnetic force we have the
photons for the strong force we have the
gluons for gravity we have graviton sand
for the weak force there are the W and Z
bosons and there's the Higgs boson and
you know in some sense the Higgs carries
a force but it's incredibly tiny
short-range very weak force so you don't
notice it all the time but it's a boson
but it's not a gauge boson it is a spin
zero scalar boson the Higgs is
responsible for the symmetry breaking
and the weak interactions that we've
talked about before but it's definitely
there we discovered it I wrote a book
about it you can read the book so we'll
definitely include it in the standard
model lots of people have tried to
figure out fun geometric ways to present
to you what are all the particles in the
standard model I think they are all kind
of artificial looking a little bit ad
hoc so I'm just gonna make a little plot
and the plot will be mass of individual
particles and on the horizontal axis we
will have the charge of the particles ok
the electrical charge different ways to
do it I think electric charge is very
noticeable there and let's you know talk
about what we call matter particles
there's also antimatter particles we'll
get to those in a minute but basically
there's just four every for most of
these matter particles there's also an
antimatter particle so we'll list the
charges that we have as minus one like
the electron there are ones that are
minus one third like the down quark
there are particles that are charge zero
and there are particles that are charged
two thirds plus two thirds so these are
not equally spaced but you get the idea
these are the ones that
be important for the standard model as
far as mass is concerned you know the
highest mass particles in the standard
model the top quark is the most massive
at around 174 GeV GeV billion electron
volts okay a proton is around 1 GeV just
for scale so I'm not gonna be very
detailed I'm not gonna get bogged down
in the five-digit decimal place accuracy
of what the mass of the different
particles are so to me the mass of the
top quark is around 100 GeV 174 is
around 100 by today's standards so let's
put a hundred GeV up there and then
let's look at there are also particles
all even put a tilde there to let you
know that we're just being order of
magnitude ish there are particles around
1 GeV there are particles around 1 MeV
that's a million electron volts ok 10 to
the sixth electron volts there's a huge
gap and there are some particles around
10 to the minus 3 electron volts that's
a little MeV milla electron volt and
then there's another a huge gap that it
won't even draw because there are other
particles around 0 electron volts
massless particles right then we can go
through we can go through the different
possibilities so let's do the bosons
first why not okay so we have the Higgs
boson Higgs is charge zero and mass 125
which by my standards now is around 100
so here is the Higgs the other massive
bosons are the W and the Z they get
their mass from the spontaneous symmetry
breaking caused by the Higgs boson so
roughly speaking they're also at that
hundred GeV level the W I'm gonna put in
the minus one charge column W minus
there's also W Plus which is its anti
particle the Higgs are sorry the Z
rather just has a single particle the Z
zero it is neutral okay so that's where
the massive bosons are the massless
bosons you know what those are you have
the photon that's charge less zero mass
you have the gluon which I will call G
and you also have the graviton which I
will call H why do I call the graviton H
well there's two reasons one is I
already used G for the gluon
so H equals graviton and why is that
well it's because when you think about
what the graviton is it's a oscillation
right it's a fluctuation a tiny little
vibration in the gravitational field the
gravitational field is given by the
metric tensor G mu nu you talked about
that a little bit and so if we're
looking at a fluctuation of that what we
generally do is write the whole metric G
mu nu as the background and the
traditional symbol for that is ADA the
Greek letter ADA is the flat background
Minkowski space special relativity
metric tensor then plus a perturbation
and since we've already used G we call
the perturbation H mu nu okay so it
doesn't matter whether you think about H
being the graviton because it's an
expansion of G and H is the next letter
after G or just because we already used
G in our table for the gluon this is why
all right
am I missing any other bosons I think
that's all the bosons why don't we do
some fermions well we have two leptons
let me see if I can make this different
color okay leptons we have the electron
that's around half an MeV so by my
standards today that's at 1 MeV and the
electron is charged minus 1 then the
electron has to heavier cousins right it
has the muon and has the towel and these
basically go right here there's the MU
there's the tau at around 1 GeV and then
you have the much lower mass neutrinos
neutrinos are also leptons there are
three of them and we traditionally
classified them as the electron neutrino
the muon neutrino and the town in torino
and roughly speaking this is not exactly
true but roughly speaking electron ness
munis and Taunus are separately
conserved so when a particle decays when
a particle which has no lepton number
decays into let's say let's say the W -
ok it can decay into an electron and an
anti-neutrino it has to be a particle
and an anti particle but the electron
has charged minus 1 neutrinos charge 0
so that works but the electron has chart
has electron number plus 1 so the
neutrino better have a lek
number minus ones that's an electron
neutrino that you make it would not be a
muon neutrino or a Tau neutrino so the
tree knows are the ones that are around
10 to minus 3 evey again we're being a
little sloppy here because we actually
haven't measured specifically what the
masses are in fact we're being sloppy
because there are three neutrino mass
states which are combinations of the
electron neutrino the town neutrino and
the muon neutrinos so guess be very
messy neutrinos can mix people live
their whole lives just studying
neutrinos and it's a a word the
occupation to study but for now our
study consists of writing down the
symbols nu e nu mu and nu tau we're not
even sure with individual masses ours
let's just group them there roughly 10
to the minus 3 electron volts okay and
then we have quarks right the quarks we
have the up quark now the up quark the
way to remember it is in a proton or two
ups and down protons are positively
charged so it better be true that ups
are positively charged and indeed an up
quark has charged plus two thirds and
the up quark is not that much more
massive than the electron is like less
than ten times as massive as the
electron even though the proton is 1800
times more massive but we talked about
that the proton gets its mass mostly
from QCD from the gluon energies inside
the proton not from the masses of its
quarks so the up quark will go over here
near the electron but in the plus
two-thirds column so that's an up quark
and then there's a charm quark at around
a GeV and the top quark way up here with
a W and the Z and the Higgs of order 100
GeV and then you have the minus
one-third quarks and you have the down
you have this strange and you have the
bottom quark again around 1 GeV and
that's it this is the standard model of
particle physics plus the graviton is
stuck in there and look you can stare at
this chart for a long time like and it's
frustrating because there are clearly
some patterns there are three families
or generations of particles right if you
if you take the electron and it's
neutrino as the lightest leptons then
you have the up quark and the down
as the latest quarks and then you have
the next family which is the the muon
and it's neutrino and the charm quark
and the strange quark and then you have
another family the tau and it's neutrino
and the top quark and the bottom Clark
but they're not exactly arranged
perfectly here I mean there's this
mismatch when minus 1/3 and plus 2/3 for
the charges more interestingly the up is
a little bit lighter than the down but
the charm is heavier than the strange
and the top is heavier way heavier than
the bottom the bottom strange and down
are comparable in mass to their charged
leptons but the neutrinos are very very
low masses and the plus 2/3 quarks are
generally heavier than the other guys
and so it like it doesn't really quite
make much sense like there there's
random numbers here it's not like these
are related by the square root of 2 or
something like that so a big goal on the
part of modern particle physics is to
understand this pattern of particles in
the standard model we're not gonna do
that today but just you know I like to
give little homework assignments for the
students out there who might be watching
this figure out this chart derive this
chart from first principles that would
be a good homework assignment okay so
what are we gonna do we're gonna talk
about how you go from this chart to
atoms okay like why do some particles
appear in atoms and not others why do
they are the atoms made of the particles
that they are well there what's
important is particles will decay okay
heavy particles decaying the lighter
ones that's because from a heavy
particle you can create several lighter
ones it's really the second law of
thermodynamics at work the second law
says entropy increases roughly speaking
for particles can have more entropy than
one particle can have one particle can
only do one thing four particles can be
arranged in lots of different ways so if
you can have one particle that can decay
into four it will but the question is
can it and one question one point is it
has to be you know more massive
otherwise you can't decay while
conserving energy the other is there can
be other conserved quantities okay like
electric charge is the most obvious one
whenever you're going to decay some
particles
the total electric charge better be
conserved but in addition to that you
have two other conserved quantities I'm
going to worry about I'm not going to
worry about
electron number muon number town number
but I will worry about baryon number so
the reason why it's called baryon
numbers because remember the quarks have
color either red green or blue and you
never see color in the real world
color is confined that it's confined
inside other particles so a baryon is a
collection of three quarks and the three
quarks one of them is red one of them is
green one of them is blue there are also
mesons
massan's are one clark and one anti
quark so the color can be confined there
because roughly if you think of red
green and blue as combining to make
white then the rule of quarks being
confined is that the of the visible
combinations of quarks that we see in
our particle physics experiments are
colorless so red green and blue counts
as colorless so a 3-quart Berry on one
red one green one blue that works that's
allowed Amazon which is a quark and an
antiquark will be red anti red blue anti
blue whatever that is also colorless so
those are the two obvious kinds of
things you can make so anyway the reason
why we talk about variant number rather
than quark numbers because variants are
what we observe baryons are these
combinations of three quarks and each
quark guess what has a bearing on number
of 1/3 so baryon number plus 1/3 goes to
all the quarks up down charm strange
bottom top and then we also have lepton
number for leptons the lepton number
plus 1 is associated with an electron
muon a Tau an electron neutrino muon
neutrino and a Tau neutrino ok and this
is going to be conserved both of these
quantities electric charge baryon number
lepton number and of course energy these
are all conserved when these particles
decay and if you have an anti particle
of any of them then you have baryon
number minus 1/3 for an anti quark or
lepton number minus 1 for an
anteye lepton there you go so those are
the rules okay so we're gonna talk about
how particles decay so decays and to do
that we're gonna use Oh actually sorry
before I talk about the decay let me
mention again let me just write down
here that the baryons are confined okay
in two colorless combinations I should
draw the picture because then it gets
into your brain I said to the words so
either had sorry and what I should say
is quarks are confined that's why I was
getting confused quarks are confined and
gluons okay but the gluons just were to
go along for the ride the quarks are
confined to color those combinations and
when there are three quarks we call them
a baryon that's why I got confused
so baryons are for example proton will
be up up down and that has bearing on
number plus one because you have three
quarks mez ons are let's say up and tied
down okay so this is a pi plus pi on how
do i knows plus well up is plus
two-thirds anti down as minus one-third
there you go
this has barium number zero so we can
make pi ons very easily and you might
think well doesn't a quark and antiquark
don't they just annihilate and the
answer is yes if they were exactly the
same and up and anti up would annihilate
very very quickly these guys do
eventually go away but we'll we'll get
to that okay so now we can get to the
decays now I can talk about that so
remember the rules are heavier particles
go to lighter ones sufficiently lighter
that the total mass of what you decay
into is less than the total mass of the
single particle that did the decaying so
the reason why energy is conserved is
because the decay
adults have energy has ADD momentum in
addition to equals mc-squared they also
have kinetic energy okay and so the
total energy the particles that the
decay products are consists of must be
moving at the right velocities so that
the total energy of the combination of
decay products adds up to the total mass
at the original particle times C squared
and lepton number baryon number and
charge are all conserved I said all
these things out loud clearly I was
getting excited and couldn't resist do
we got to the point of writing them but
there you go okay and we're gonna
discuss the decays in terms of Fineman
diagrams okay so we're gonna draw the
Fineman diagram lines the Higgs boson is
special because the only spin zero
particle in the fundamental standard
model chart so it gets a dashed line it
looks like that the fermions all of them
kind of look the same in terms of
fireman diagrams or just straight lines
and I will draw Fermi on number as the
arrow there so the arrow does not mean
momentum this arrow does not mean the
direction which the particles moving it
means the direction which the Fermi on
number is flowing so an anti particle
will have the arrow pointing the other
way and then you have the gauge bosons
and those will be wavy lines
because it's kind of like light right I
like radiation gauge bosons so what I
wanted to establish is that most of
these particles just decay away and the
ones that don't go into making atoms in
some complicated way there is a rule in
this game
we're nature you know apparently
Einstein once said that nature is subtle
but not malicious but you would think
sometimes that nature is malicious the
way that things work out here in the
standard model it gets very very
complicated like every complication that
you might worry about ends up actually
being true in the standard model okay so
let's go through and figure out how
things decay and we're just going to go
through all these particles and ask can
they decay or can they not given these
rules okay so the Higgs can decay
certainly in fact it can decay in a few
ways so the Higgs
couples to both fermions and to gauge
bosons in ways yeah the Higgs itself has
no conserved quantities other than
energy right it has zero charge zero
spin zero lepton number zero baryon
number I was hesitating there's a thing
you've spin spin is also conserved but
it can be it's part of angular momentum
so it's not conserved by itself
therefore it enters into the Fineman
diagram is in a more subtle way that's
why we're not doing it explicitly we
don't need to use it for any of these
purposes so eggs can decay for example I
don't know pick whatever you want it can
decay into electron and a positron ki +
oops and here's H there you go that's
the decay it could also decay into two
quarks so here is a quark let me be
careful about this I mean let me draw
this picture a little bit bigger for
reasons that will become clear so here's
a quark here's an anti quark and here's
the Higgs so the Higgs can decay into
that the problem is the quark and the
antiquark can't just go their own way
all by themselves cuz quarks are
confined right so you might worry that
this doesn't happen or it just decays
into a single mess on which is a quark
antiquark pair but that can't happen
because then it's one particle the Higgs
decaying into one other particle the
Mazon and that just can't happen unless
those particles have exactly the same
energy which they wouldnt which there's
no mess on that has exactly the energy
of the Higgs so what can possibly happen
well one thing that could happen is one
of these quarks could give off let's say
a Z boson and then that can decay into
an antiquark and a quark and now you
have two mesons being produced okay so
the here's of how the diagrams become
more complicated because there's a
million different constraints you have
to satisfy when you ask how these
processes actually happen and then what
you would want to do is actually
calculate the rate of this happening and
that might be hard this doesn't need to
be a Z in fact it's more likely it could
be a Z but
is much more likely to be a gluon right
because gluons are strongly coupled
QCD is strongly coupled whereas the W
bosons or the Z bosons are weakly
coupled so this is a much more likely
diagram in fact it's so likely that you
should probably be including a lot more
gluons in there and becomes very very
complicated very very hard to calculate
again full employment for professional
particle physicists and there are other
ways you know I'm not gonna list all the
possible decay modes of the Higgs but
one thing that it can do is decay into
two quarks as we said before I should
draw the little arrows like I said I
would
on the quark lines on the Fermi on lines
so here's a quark here's a Higgs going
into a quark antiquark pair and what
could happen is that they can spit off
let's say photons there's a quark here's
an anti quark by creating a little
closed loop of quark I can label that Q
or anti Q it doesn't matter because it's
a vertical line which means it could be
either going forward in time or backward
in time if it's going backward it's an
anti quark it's going forward it's a
quark and then another photon comes out
here so this is a way that the Higgs can
decay into two photons again you see how
complicated it gets in fact the Higgs is
decaying two photons if I'm remembering
it correctly this is not a very common
way the Higgs decays maybe like one
percent at the time but it sticks out
above the background if we were doing a
different set of videos talking about
experimental particle physics someone
else would have to do them but one of
the biggest challenges is not just
seeing things that you're looking for
but making sure they are really
statistically significant over and above
other things other ways the same thing
could happen so you know you don't ever
see a Higgs boson in the Large Hadron
Collider I know that you think that we
found it what we've found is the decay
products of the Higgs so we see two
protons smashing into each other a bunch
of particles come out and two of them
are high-energy photons and you say well
what would I expect the rate of that to
be in the absence of the Higgs boson
existing and I compare it to the actual
rate and they say AHA there must be a
Higgs boson there too
account for that fact just this I know
this is going off of off schedule here
but as a function of energy so you could
look for two photons being created in
the Smashing of two protons together at
the Large Hadron Collider okay and
there's a jillion ways for that to
actually happen and what you would
predict is as the energy energy gets
higher this is the total energy of the
two photons being produced okay without
the Higgs you'd expect it to be you know
harder and harder to make high-energy
photons there'd be some rate so this is
the rate or the total number of events
that you see in your detector okay you
just run this for a very very long time
but what you actually see is something
like this you see a bump okay so you see
what you expected plus an excess and
that excess is at the energy of the two
photons equals the mass of the Higgs 125
GeV that's how you measure the mass of
the Higgs it's from the total energy of
the photons or whatever that it turns
into okay there's a there's a million
complications in particle physics so we
can easily get out of hand here but take
that for granted the Higgs decays away
very quickly one Zepto second is the
lifetime of the Higgs boson for the W or
the Z you've got a very similar thing
let's just say let's imagine you have a
w- okay so there you can't just decay
into two photons because two photons
have total zero charge and w- has charge
minus one what can you do well you know
what you can do you could have an
electron let me get my arrow pointing
the right direction here
there's my electron so that's carrying
the charge and then you went from zero
lepton number 2-1 lips sorry to plus one
lepton number therefore you better make
up for it by making something with zero
charge and minus one lepton number and
you know what that is that is a lek tron
antineutrino there you go and this can
also happen very quickly you can play
the same game for the Z bosons for
example alright so where are we well we
have quarks
let's look at what the heavy quarks can
do so the charm the strange the bottom
the top by heavy quarks I mean anything
other than that up and down okay
and they can decay very very quickly
roughly speaking you know when a heavy
particle decays into lighter particles
there's a rate at which that decay
happens and there are two things that
help you figure out what that rate is
one is how strongly is the coupling that
makes the decay happen so if you can
decay through the strong interactions
like over here that's why I did this
gluon picture right here this gluon
would be the primary way of having this
thing happen because that's a strong
interaction that happens all the time
whereas if you need the weak
interactions like the W boson decay
needs that's a slower kind of decay so
that's one thing you need the other the
other thing that goes into it is how
much room do you have to decay so if
you're a massive particle decaying into
a set of particles with lower mass do
the total masses of the particles you're
decaying into come close to what your
mass was that means only have a tiny
little window in fact what we say is you
have a tiny amount of phase space to
decay into and that makes your decay
slower whereas if you can decay into
much later particles then you have a lot
of phase space a lot of different ways
to distribute the energies that came
from your e equals mc-squared
into your decay products and that lets
the decay go faster so the top quark and
the bottom quark for example decay by
very similar ways but because the top
quark is so much heavier it will decay
much much faster so what's a typical
decay well the top quark for example
could turn into a down quark let's
remember top quark is charge plus
two-thirds down quark is charge minus
one-third okay so the charge has to go
somewhere
plus 2/3 1/2 minus 1/3 let's imagine
that what happened is a w+ got made and
that w plus well that can decay then
let's imagine that decays into a
neutrino and a positron the anti
particle
the electron right which has a charge
plus one things like that this is just
one example of many many many but anyway
all these quarks can decay very quickly
likewise the heavy leptons can decay
very quickly the mew and the Tao the mew
actually can't decay that quickly is
it's pretty light and it can only decay
through the weak interactions it's for
both the weakness of the interaction and
the amount of phase space it has there's
not that much this it's hard for it to
decay so it leaves a relatively long
lifetime by the standards of elementary
particles but it can decay so here's a
mew - and it can decay for example into
neutrino the muon neutrino by emitting
let's see well it went from minus 1 to 0
charge so it had better emit a charged
particle like the w- then guess what the
w- can decay for example into an
electron and an anti-neutrino and
likewise the Tau the tab decays also
pretty quickly because it's heavier than
the muon finally so the neutrinos
themselves can't decay they can turn
into each other
there's no lighter lepton right there's
no lighter Fermi on than the neutrino
and since Fermi on number is conserved
there's no word for the neutrinos to go
but they can because neutrinos mix with
each other appear to change into each
other right a muon neutrino and a town
something can be created in the form of
a muon neutrino and be detected in the
form of the Tau neutrino of conditions
in between are correct but we're gonna
ignore that it's not really the total
number of neutrinos isn't changing when
those decays happen the final thing that
can happen is that the quarks that do
get together can get together in
combinations that don't live forever
right so mesons can decay in fact there
are no completely stable mesons I said
let's take the PI plus the positively
charged PI on there's a pi minus a PI 0
pi plus these are the lightest mesons
out there and the pi plus is just an up
quark and an anti down okay
that's the combination that it is and
what could happen is the down is a
little bit lighter than the up but these
can come together it's a true fact that
down a little bit later
but it's irrelevant to what I'm about to
say what could happen is that you know
in the world of Fineman diagrams you
know that the intermediate lines in
Fineman diagrams represent virtual
particles so they're not real particles
so I can temporarily have them be any
energy I want it's not that energy
conservation is violated it says they
can have whatever energy I want so I can
create a virtual W boson so I can
imagine these two particles come
together to make a W it it better be a W
plus because I have a positive charge
flowing through this diagram and this W
Plus virtual W plus can have exactly the
right energy to be the PI on as long as
it then decays so it can decay the way
that we've seen the W plus decay over
here into let's say an electron neutrino
and a positron there you go so a single
Payan can just decay just like that into
a electron and neutrino and you see that
even though the Payan is a strongly
interacting particle even though it's
Amazon it has net very on number zero
because of the quark and an antiquark
likewise its decay products here have
net lepton number zero because it's a
lepton in anti lepton so all the
conservation laws are being perfectly
well respected ha so as you see most of
these particles decay away in fact they
decay away pretty quickly what are we
left with well it's a pretty familiar
story we're left with the massless
unconfined gauge bosons the massive
gauge bosons the W and Z s decay the
massless gluons are confined inside
hadron so in terms of the particles that
you see you can see massless unconfined
gauge bosons namely the photon gamma and
the graviton H graviton I'll remind you
I know you don't see gravitons but you
see gravity which is can be thought of
as the collective force due to many many
many many gravitons you also get
neutrinos
they're allowed to stick around
NUI new Moo new town you have electrons
remember your tree knows concerning to
each other they don't actually decay
electrons just sit around there you go
II - they're heavier cousins do decay
into them and then you have up and down
quarks confined into
hadrons in fact hadrons remember
hydrants are the collections of sorry
baryons are collections of three
particles hadrons that's that's I wanted
to say these combined are called hadrons
okay hydrants are any collections of
strongly directing particles namely
quarks and gluons and these are confined
to headphones in particular I didn't
want to say hey drones I want to say
they're combining to light a particular
kind of had drawn light colorless
baryons namely there are two of them the
proton up up down and the neutron up
down down okay so these are the two that
can hang around now there's a subtlety
because like I said there's a million
subtleties going on here the neutron
proton you might say to yourself well
wait a minute the down is heavier than
the up and you told me that heavier
particles want to decay so shouldn't the
lightest baryon be three up quarks
isn't that the lightest thing that you
can make there are particles with made
of three up quarks there's the there are
Delta baryons okay but remember the
Polly exclusion principle you can't have
two particles in the same state and so
if I have two ups and a down their wave
functions can be the same because
they're different kinds of particles
they're not identical particles and up
and down are not identical but two up
quarks are identical so it turns out I'm
skipping some steps but it turns out if
you try to squeeze three up core
into the same baryon you can do it but
only by having them be a little bit more
energetic than they otherwise would be
in particular their spins have to be
pointing in the same direction so it
costs a little bit more energy that's
like the heavier particle so the masses
of baryons are not just the sums of the
masses of the quarks they're made out of
it turns out in the real world the
lightest baryon is the proton with two
ups and a down
but what about two downs and up I mean
that's not the lightest very on neutrons
are heavier than protons so shouldn't
they decay the answer is yes neutrons do
decay and then your question is well why
don't or rather why do we see neutrons
all over the place why do we live in a
world which is you know literally the
earth or I'm pretty sure that your body
is most of its masses in the form of
neutrons not in the form of protons or
electrons why is that well let's first
explain how they decay a neutron and
zero is an up a down and another down
okay it's a collection of those three
quarks and the way it decays is that one
of those downs turns into an up okay
which we know can happen by the W bosons
so just imagine this this this here are
your particles your quarks carrying
their Fermi on number but the down which
is charged minus one-third admits a W
minus to become an up quark and now you
have two ups in a down and this is
called a proton and the W minus does its
thing it turns into electron and
electron there you go so this can happen
absolutely neutrons do decay but here's
the thing the total mass of proton plus
electron plus neutrino is less than the
mass of the neutron but not by much so
you go to the details here let me see I
looked it up I don't remember these
things the mass of the neutron minus the
mass of the proton plus the mass of the
electron plus the mass of the neutrino
divided by the mass of the neutron is
about 0.1%
it's a tiny number so the phase space
for a neutron to decay
is very tiny and the decay happens via
the W boson which is a weakly
interacting particle so the decay is
very slow so the lifetime tau Neutron
again I don't know the exact numbers but
it's about 10 minutes which is very
short on the timescale the age of the
universe but hugely long on the
timescale of most elementary particles
the Higgs boson decays in a Zepto ii
remember so that's because of this
conspiracy where the neutrino with the
neutron is just a little bit heavier
than the proton so neutrons can live a
long time again you know cosmologically
speaking that's not a long time but
that's why you can find neutrons out
there in the world and before going on
so the thing that will go on to is to
say that once you can combine neutrons
with protons then they can live forever
in the right circumstances so the you
can have neutrons more than ten minutes
past the birth of the universe okay but
what I want to mention is that you know
this is a weird fine-tuning in the laws
of nature you know I'm not gonna say
that God did it because I don't believe
that's true but I'm not gonna hide from
the fact that in the standard model of
particle physics there are some weird
coincidences going on and these weird
coincidences seem to us to help us exist
there's some other weird coincidences
have nothing to do with our existence so
you know and it's not don't make too
much of it but what if you know what if
the masses of the particles were just
slightly different where the interaction
strengths were slightly different so
that the mass of the proton was greater
than the mass of the neutron right now
the mass of neutron is a little bit
bigger than the mass of the proton what
if it were the other way around it's
very easy to imagine jiggling with the
masses of the quarks to make this happen
okay because we have no principle from
which to derive the masses of the quarks
so we can at least easily imagine a
universe in which neutrons are a little
bit lighter so in that case protons
would decay into neutrons because
protons would be heavier if the protons
were you know enough heavier they could
spit out a positron and turn to a
neutron and that would happen and the
positrons that were created by decaying
protons would annihilate eventually with
any electron
so we're out there and then you be left
with a world of neutrons there would be
no protons around
so because neutrons are a little bit
heavier than protons you end up with a
rule where there are both protons and
electrons and then complicated things
happen to make sure there are some
neutrons lying around also but at least
there are two different kinds of
particles protons and electrons that
have electromagnetic interactions and
that's as we're gonna say soon that's
what makes the world an interesting
place
if neutrons were lighter than protons
you would have no charge particles lying
around you would just have neutrons and
then the question becomes can you make
stars can you make life can you make
anything interesting in a world that is
just made of neutrons and the answer
might be no but you know but I don't
know for sure like you can't make life
as we know it if the world were nothing
but neutrons but could you make other
things that I cannot quite conceive of
because my brain is too tiny and I don't
have the ability to envision what life
would be like in a role was nothing but
neutrons I don't know that's it's
interesting and worth thinking about but
this is a feature of the world is that
the proton is a little bit lighter than
the neutron and thank goodness for us
being here okay the in the real world
this is the fake world the world
neutrons in the real world neutrons can
be stable if they're inside certain
kinds of atomic nuclei so stable I mean
never decays nuclei are just collections
of neutrons protons stuck together with
it's basically we're not gonna go into
this but again another whole area of
physics that many many people devote
their lives to is nuclear physics right
all we've said is that protons and
neutrons are made of quarks and if the
quarks inside the protons and neutrons
are held together by gluons but what
that leaves is a little bit of extra
force that can actually stick protons
and neutrons together so it's much like
even though atoms are neutral even
though you know two hydrogen atoms are
neutral you might say well they're
electrically neutral there's no force
between them but actually is a tiny
force between them because a little
leftover remnant force the two hydrogen
atoms
wanted to come together as well discuss
in just a second likewise even though to
a neutron and a proton are colorless
there's still a little bit of remnant
nuclear force that wants them to come
together in fact it's pretty strong as
it works out so that's how you can make
atomic nuclei so for example the
deuteron here's an example of a deuteron
which is one proton and one Neutron
stuck together
you can never accurately draw this
deuterons are actually very very close
to spherical neutron and the proton are
sitting right on top of each other in
the deuteron they're not like here's the
proton here's the neutron and some
dumbbell shape okay but it's hard to
draw that so you always draw it this way
this is the deuteron it's a isotope of
hydrogen you know I'm not gonna remind
you of all the chemistry in the world
but we classify nuclei by the number of
protons and so this has one proton and
it's as a kind of hydrogen the deuteron
and you can figure out you can actually
go either measure it or do ab initio
calculations and nuclear physics and you
find that the mass of the deuteron
is I gotta look this up one eight seven
5.6 MeV okay close to twice the mass of
the proton or twice massive neutron but
not exactly and then you can say well
can it decay right this is the game that
we playing say like well can the neutron
in that proton in that deuteron decay
well it would decay into a proton
presumably and then you have two protons
and two protons cannot stick together
that's a lot more energy than just two
protons individually because they have
electromagnetic repulsion the strong
nuclear force would like them to come
together but two protons without any
neutrons hanging around the strong
nuclear force loses that battle and the
electromagnetic force pushes them apart
so that Neutron has to decay into a
proton and that proton has to go its own
way so they have to be separate so you
compare the mass of the neutron of the
deuteron to the mass of a proton Plus
what the neutron decays into proton plus
an electron plus an anti neutrino and
that works out to be one eight seven
seven point
1mev so in order for the deuteron
to decay would have to decay into
particles that are heavier than it is
which means it doesn't happen which
means the deuteron is stable that's why
and you want to say well why is the
master on that that's too complicated
that's above our pay grade for these
videos but it's the the combination of
many many things going on inside the
Deuter on the strong nuclear force the
weak nuclear force the masses of the
quarks the whole shebang the point is
that under these circumstances and in
heavier nuclei as well the deuteron can
in fact be stable and in fact logic like
that leads you to all the isotopes all
the isotopes in the periodic table the
elements right so what we care about
here you know the periodic table is what
you care about if you're a chemist
because the periodic table the columns
in the table are telling you something
about the chemical properties of the
atoms but if you're just dealing with
the nuclear physics it's the isotopes
that matter to you not the individual
chemical elements and it turns out and I
had to look this up how many stable
isotopes are there would you guess do
you know any nuclear physicists out
there in the audience there are about
250 stable and I'll put stable in quotes
isotopes and that's because why is
stable in quotes because you know this
is a really close battle as you see from
you know the closeness of these two
numbers for the deuteron and it's its
purported decay products on the one hand
when you try to make a nucleus you're
already fighting against the fact that
protons are positively charged and
neutrons are neutral so there's no
negatively charged particles in the
nucleus so there's a repulsion like
charges repel protons do not want to be
brought close to each other that's why
nuclear fusion is hard and why we do not
have effective cheap fusion energy
powering our reactors ok because getting
the protons close to each other is very
very difficult on the other hand you
have the fact that if it works the
energy the mass can be a little bit
lower so they want to be there so they
want to be there but there's a barrier
that's why nuclear fusion is hard
and when and when I say they want to be
there it's not by a lot like the
deuteron is not that difficult to break
apart you know a strong gamma-ray
hitting a deuteron can just break it
apart pretty easily so the there's this
combination where the strong nuclear
force wants the baryons to come together
the electromagnetic repulsion pushes
them apart you need some neutrons in
there because neutrons will give you
some extra strong nuclear force but too
many neutrons will just decay because
neutrons want to decay so there's all
this combination this complicated
combination of forces counteracting each
other and that's why you know that it's
complicated to do nuclear physics and
the reason why to finally finish this
sentence the reason why it's 250 stable
nuclei is there are 250 isotopes rather
250 isotopes that as far as we know
would never decay in an observable
amount of time okay we think though that
only 80 of them or so are truly stable
so by which we mean there's another you
know 170 which will linger around for
many many many many many years and then
eventually decay that is what we think
will actually happen anyway that's this
is the reason why I'm doing this is
because these are the low energy allowed
stable particles in the standard model
particle physics so well we're left with
is I said what we're left with is this
stuff right but then we had to go into
some details about how the baryons get
together so the world the world of you
and me and the tables and the Sun and
the moon and stars is made of electrons
around 250 stable isotopes
neutrinos you know they exist they're
out there but they pass right through
you writing you probably heard this fact
like a neutrino that it comes out of the
Sun will probably pass right through the
entire earth without ever being stopped
because it's nuclear it's a weak nuclear
interaction is so weak so even though
neutrinos are there they don't affect
our lives very much and so let's let's
get down to the physics of our everyday
lives literally the table and chairs our
biology and things like that so forget
about the neutrinos forget them and then
you have this is the matter of the world
and then you have the forces which are
electromagnetism right photons and
gravity and those are the forces and
that's it that's the world this is the
world again that you and I are made out
of there are we're relieving some bits
out in this very very simplified
discussion because they're basically
what we're leaving out is the weak
nuclear force and neutrinos because
they're very rare and they don't have a
lot to do with what we're what we care
about everything else everything else
that you make from the standard model
either decays away very quickly or
interacts with us very very weakly so we
don't need to worry about it so it's
interesting that this is sort of the
leftover low-energy remnants of the
standard model of particle physics it
was it's a complicated story to get
there that we just raced through an
incredibly high speed but you know
everything in the world that you
encounter in your everyday life unless
you're a working physicist is made of
this stuff so you know not just tables
and chairs volcanoes and hurricanes and
bacteria and plants and people
psychology art literature music sound
and light it's all some combination of
this stuff in interesting ways of course
the ways are very very interesting and
if someone said you know write a sonnet
or write a symphony you would not start
with the standard model of particle
physics and try to drive it from first
principles that would be another video
that we'll talk about but these are the
ingredients this is all you need and
that that's kind of amazing I'll name
one more fact I want to talk about
mostly some put that putting things
these together now to get atoms and so
forth but an extra fact is there is an
asymmetry in imbalance between matter
and antimatter thing is fact right
there's more matter in the universe than
antimatter in fact you know we don't
even know that for sure you know it's
really a symmetry and baryon number that
we know about so we know that in the
observable universe there's a lot more
baryon number than anti variant number
why not because when you say matter and
antimatter
I mean you mean something like lepton
number plus baryon number is matter anti
lepton number and anti barian number is
antimatter we know the baryon number of
the universe because baryons are protons
and neutrons and they're very easy to
notice we can find them fairly easily
but lepton number an anti lepton number
can be hidden in neutrinos and the total
number of neutrinos in the universe is
very hard to count so what we know is
that in the charged particles and then
the strongly nuclear force interacting
particles there's a big imbalance
between matter and antimatter
but maybe it's made up for in the
neutrinos that we don't know but there's
certainly an imbalance in baryon number
we don't know why so there's two
possibilities and one of them is not
very plausible one possibility is that
somehow the universe is born with a
slight imbalance between baryon number
and anti baryon number that's hard to
imagine it being true you have to do it
in exactly the right way because barring
on number even in the standard model is
not a hundred percent super-duper
conserved under the right circumstances
it can vary but also it just seem weird
like why should there be an imbalance
the other is exactly because we can
imagine processes that do violate baryon
number it's again full employment for
theoretical physicists to invent what we
call baryogenesis schemes schemes where
in the early universe as it expands and
cools there are particles that decay and
interact with each other which
end up producing a few more baryons than
anti baryons
you can run the numbers what you need in
the very early universe is at very early
times when temperatures were much higher
than the mass of the proton there was a
lot of both baryons and anti baryons and
most of them decay away most of them
annihilate with each other turn into
photons or something like that as the
universe expands and cools what you need
is roughly speaking for if I'm gonna get
the number right for every 10 billion
anti baryons you need to have 10 billion
and one baryons at very very early times
so all but one of every ten billion
baryons and anti baryons annihilate away
and you're left with the tiny little
remnant which makes up all the stuff
that we see today so I'm not going to
talk about that but that is something
that you need you need to understand why
all these particles why there's this
imbalance there we don't really know ok
so here now we're gonna reach sort of
the punchline of really what I wanted to
talk about so these are our ingredients
for the physics of everyday life
electrons stable nuclear isotopes
electromagnetism and gravity ok the weak
nuclear force is too weak the strong
nuclear force is only in the isotopes
don't need to worry about those the
Higgs boson is far too weak the heavier
fermions decay away this is what we're
left with so there's only two kinds of
matter right nuclei and electrons and
there's only two forces two big
long-range forces that are important in
the everyday world so think about those
forces just a little bit there are only
two of them and one of them is gravity
and gravity I'm gonna hate to say this
but gravity is dumb I don't mean that
it's dumb to think about gravity or to
care about it I just mean that how
gravity acts on the world is simple it
pulls things together there's slight
complications if you talk about dark
energy or something like that or
inflation in the early universe but
again we're trying to understand the
everyday world we're trying to
understand what's happening right here
right now in the room that you're in
okay so the pen Falls toward the earth
that's all that ever happens with
gravity just tracks things together with
an in
square law it's incredibly simple okay
whereas electromagnetism is interesting
let's say it's clever I just made that
up right now but I think it's true and
the reason why you know the reason why
is when we talked about gravity we
talked about the principle equivalence
right all particles fall at the same
rate in a gravitational field not only
is all the gravity does is pull things
together it pulls everything together in
exactly the same way whereas enm
electromagnetism
acts on you differently depending on if
you're positively charged negatively
charged or neutral so E&M can both push
and pull it pushes it pulls things
together if they've opposite charges it
pushes them apart if they have the same
charge so what that means is what
electromagnetism can do has an
infinitely greater variety than what
gravity can do because you know gravity
you you might think it's just like you
know gravity does one thing and electro
nate ism does two things so how much
more important can it be but you can
balance you can play them off against
each other and in fact the world does
that then the entire reason the world is
interesting can ultimately come down to
the fact that electromagnetism is clever
because there are positive and negative
charges in the world so this explains
you know this accounts for electricity a
Hall of electricity comes down to this
fact electricity comes about because you
know you have these atoms will pop at
atoms in a second but atoms with these
heavy nuclei and very light electrons
and the electrons can be pushed around
because they're much lighter than the
nuclei and they're charged so they can
be pushed around by electromagnetic
fields so if you just gather together a
bunch of electrons so you have minus
charges on one side of something and
then end or oops combine a bunch of
positive charges on the other side but
photons over here okay then if you put
an electron in between it's gonna zoom
over to the positive charges and we call
that electricity okay so in the very
very likely condition that you are
currently watching this on an electronic
device you should thank your lucky stars
that there are positive and negative
charges in the world because that's what
lets us manipulate the electrons going
through that device to create
electronics and electricity okay it's
ultimately because of this feature of
the standard model of particle physics
the other thing this explains is
chemistry you can tell that we're not
going to go into details in any of these
higher-level concepts but I want you
know to connect them to the underlying
world beneath chemistry is again there's
a push in the pole but in this case it's
a little bit more subtle
I mean electricity is very subtle also
like once you had the superconductivity
and all this stuff extremely subtle or
even circuit boards for that matter but
I want to talk about the subtlety in
chemistry because it harkens back to our
discussion of the pallidly exclusion
principle right so just think about you
know eg a hydrogen molecule so hydrogen
molecule just two hydrogen atoms so the
point is that let me draw it this way
whoo it's not very good but okay there's
a proton another proton and in this
cloud or two electrons okay the point is
that around one hydrogen atom you could
imagine you can put one electron no
problem around one nucleus there's still
room for one more electron in there as
we'll discuss in a second so in a sense
there want to be two electrons hugging
that single proton but there's not
enough electric charge to make that
happen right once you have the proton
and one electron it's done attracting
things roughly speaking but if you have
two hydrogen atoms they're happiest the
electron sort of wanted to combine the
electrons want to both be hugging either
one of those protons they want to pull
them together but of course then the
protons begin to push things apart right
the protons have a pod
electric charge and you know there's
also the pala exclusion principle so you
have to have the electrons lined up in
the right way and what you get at the
end of the day is you can have a
potential energy and this is this are
here is the distance between the two
protons okay so you can say what is the
what are the forces acting on the
protons if they're very close together
the protons push each other apart
okay there's electrons but the electrons
are all spread out around them so
they're not going to help that much in
ameliorating the electric repulsion
between the protons so it costs energy
to go very close by but also if they're
far away they want to be a little bit
closer so what you get at the end of the
day is a curve that looks like this
which says this is the potential energy
between the two protons and there's a
favorite place to live there's a
favorite distance to have between those
two things and it's all because of some
complex interplay of electromagnetism
and the pellet exclusion principle okay
and so this is why you can get molecules
sticking together while you can get two
atoms that want to come together okay
it's again ultimately because of quantum
field theory in gauge theory and other
things like that they wouldn't have told
you that in your chemistry class but
chemistry is just applied
electromagnetism in a world that has the
Pauli exclusion principle in it so let's
actually let's let's talk about that in
a little bit more detail let's finally
get to atoms we're like more than an
hour in and now we're into the to the
video and we're finally getting to the
to the title atoms so we have of course
hydrogen atoms which is just one proton
plus one electron the simplest one
there can be isotopes there can be ions
you know all that stuff we're often get
into that but basically it's the simple
thing you know the electrons have wave
functions as we discussed before but you
know what hydrogen is about helium okay
so by the way for hydrogen if you have a
deuteron instead of a proton so if you
have the combination of the neutron and
approach
you get basically the same hydrogen you
get what we call deuterium but
chemically it's the same it's the
electron that is doing all the chemistry
this is the point of this little
monologue up here is that the electrons
are doing the work in chemistry the
protons are being pushed and pulled but
it's the electrons that are doing the
pushing in the pulling the protons
interacting themselves or just going
along for the ride so so hydrogen with a
deuterium in the in the middle the
Deuter on in the middle sent mr. proton
is pretty similar a little bit heavier
heavy heavy water right heavy hydrogen
helium two protons two neutrons two
electrons and something is already
happening interesting with helium
because of physics because of the power
of the exclusion principle right so the
poly exclusion principle
remember says that two identical
particles cannot be in exactly the same
quantum state okay so if you have a
helium nucleus
this is our little helium nucleus two
protons two neutrons and I'm just gonna
like do this terrible sort of Rutherford
atom kind of picture that you know is
not right
but it gets the point across two
electrons like that okay really the
electrons have wave functions really the
electrons want to be in the lowest
energy wave function they can be in but
they can't be in exactly the same wave
function because that would violate the
Pauli exclusion principle because
electrons are indistinguishable
particles okay
happily happily for life and for
chemistry sorry poly solution principle
no two identical particles can be in
exact
same state happily electrons head spin
okay so these two electrons have two
spins and all you need to do to put them
in the same shape of the wave function
is to let the spins be oppositely
aligned one spin up and one spin down or
as you know from our explorations of
entanglement you could say spin right
and spin left but they're oppositely
aligned they're entangled with each
other in opposite directions so the
electrons in helium have opposite spins
so you can put two electrons with wave
functions that have the same shape as
long as their spin wave functions are
different that is satisfying the
solution principle okay but then you're
done
in terms of this thing that electrons
can do you can't put a third electron in
there doing the same thing there's only
two values for spin spin up and spin
down you've used it up the electron is a
spin 1/2 particle ok so now this is the
origin of why Heydrich of why helium is
a noble gas why helium does not interact
why there are not helium molecules the
helium has its electrons filling the
thing that they can fill the those two
electrons are in their lowest energy
state the lowest energy shell as we
would call it and that's all you can fit
there there's no more room for
interesting chemistry the electrons
don't want to be in someone else's orbit
or anything like that like the hydrogen
atom did the helium electrons are
perfectly happy where they are so helium
is roughly speaking non interacting
chemically but we can keep going what's
the next one beryllium three beryllium
three four three protons atomic number
three okay in fact I'm not gonna do
believe me I'm not gonna do the whole
periodic table the elements from
beryllium up to neon okay this is
filling the next
shell of electrons and we can actually
roughly appreciate why that's true you
know any now I've been previously
apologizing to mathematicians and
particle physicists now I will apologize
any chemists in the audience because
we're not going to do justice to all the
complications here but roughly we can
understand why this makes sense the
point is that when we did electron wave
functions right the electron wants to be
close to the proton and so what we can
do is to plot as a function of distance
from the proton we can plot the electron
wave function Tsai and the lowest energy
one looks roughly like this okay and
that's both of the helium electrons are
gonna be doing that in space Tsai as a
function of R so what's next what is the
next highest energy thing so we cannot
put any more electrons in that lowest
energy level and it turns out there are
two different things that you can do so
what you might guess is that you you can
sort of let the thing what should I say
I'll just tell you the answer and then
I'll back up and justify it okay here's
the answer what I will plot here is a
wave function that actually looks like
it shouldn't be the next highest one and
then I will separately plot over here a
different thing but instead of R which
is just the distance from the center I
will write X because what I mean is the
specific direction in space X and then I
will plot what you probably were
expecting so this is a wave function
here that only crosses zero once the
yellow one over here crosses it twice
and so what you're thinking is well it
costs energy for a wave function to
change for a wave function have a
gradient okay so when an electron wants
to be in his lowest energy orbital it
wants to change is gradual
as possible its wavefunction so that's
clearly what the white one does it
changes very very smoothly the green one
changes a little bit more the yellow one
changes a little bit faster and as you
go up and up and up at energy you'll get
more and more Wiggles in the
wavefunction that makes perfect sense
but it turns out that the yellow and the
green are of approximately equal energy
and the reason why is because the same
reason why I wrote R over here and X
over here this yellow wave function is
symmetric you notice that as you send R
goes to minus R it looks exactly the
same and in fact it can be spiritedly
symmetric so it can vary in the r
direction but there's no variation going
on in the XY or z directions it's a
perfectly spherical e symmetric thing
whereas this green one over here changes
sign as you go from left to right so it
can't be spherical e symmetric and very
roughly speaking if you've ever seen the
pictures of you know the nucleus and
then different electron orbitals so
there's an orbital these orbitals look
like this and if I can do it correctly
well I can't do it correctly here but
it's spherically symmetric that's all
I'm gonna get across whereas these
orbitals you've seen pictures that look
like this where they're like P orbitals
oops that's not the one I wanted
they look like they're double-lobed ok
and guess what they can be doubled in 3
different directions so if I count how
many ways so there are two orbitals like
this two states why because they're two
spins only one spatial wave function but
two different spin alignments here there
are three different orbital wave
functions one with the two lobes in the
X Direction y direction and Z direction
and then there are two spins for each of
them so there are six states for this so
there are a total of eight states for
the electrons in these next level
orbitals so when I hope is that the
numbers work out correctly so I said
that hydrogen is one helium has two
electrons and this next shell goes from
beryllium to neon so that's from three
to ten
inclusive so that's eight different
elements and exactly what we got the
eight states there okay so all this is a
very very fancy way of saying that all
that stuff you learn in chemistry is
ultimately because of features of
particle physics in some sense now you
don't need to know all these features of
particle physics typically in high
school people take chemistry before they
take quantum mechanics but there is some
relationship there it's not completely
separate okay and from there you just
keep going you just make things more and
more complicated and there's a
complicated story of how the different
electron orbitals get filled etc and
that's you know the life of a chemist so
just show you one example carbon which
has six protons so if the six protons
have six electrons attracted to them two
of those electrons will be in this
lowermost helium like orbit or hydrogen
like if you want and then four of them
will be in the next shell the next set
of orbitals and so if you have four in
four of these eight are filled so you
have four filled electron states in the
orbitals and four open open for business
and that's why carbon is interesting
that's why carbon is the backbone of
life because it has the most number of
interesting things going on it has split
its electrons it has four electrons to
play with and it has four electrons it
can take so it's sort of maximally
interactive so you end up doing what
what is called organic chemistry okay so
you have you know carbon atoms sticking
to each other and then also other atoms
so typically the simplest thing in the
world is to put hydrogen atoms
everywhere right to get hydro
hydrocarbons but you can do other things
you can put like an oxygen atom and if
you go through the little thing that we
did there oxygen has two open slots and
you can finish that so that's a nice
little example like this is a very
famous molecule that you could look up
of an organic chemistry molecule we're
not gonna do organic chemistry any
detail we're not gonna do chemistry in
detail we're done with chemistry that's
what I wanted to tell you about
chemistry what I wanted to tell you
about chemistry is it all comes down to
electromagnetism and a poly exclusion
principle it's all just an application
of that okay one final thing one final
thought before I let you go for this
video here and the final thought is I'm
gonna write down very explicitly here
because this gets very easily
misinterpreted if quantum field theory
is basically correct you know we never
know right
quantum field theory is by far and away
the best currently applicable theory we
have explaining the world at a
fundamental level it might not be
completely correct in fact what we know
about quantum gravity suggests the
quantum field theory is not completely
correct but quantum gravity is very far
away from our experimental reach so
again if we're trying to explain the
world at the everyday then quantum field
theory seems to be a good way of doing
it then we will never it's very hard to
say never in physics but this is a
conditional sentence if quantum field
theory is correct
then we will never discover new
particles or forces relevant to everyday
physics
what do i mean by this
by everyday physics I mean the stuff
that you literally see around you right
now given that I'm presuming you are not
working in a particle accelerator or a
telescope or anything like that
the stuff that you're touching ok the
stuff that you're made of yourself
everything you're visibly seeing with
your eyes or you know touching with your
fingers that's everyday physics the
physics of tables and chairs planets and
stars stuff like that ok we know what
that stuff is made of it's made of the
list that I showed you before the
electrons the isotopes electromagnetism
and gravity that's what you need if you
want to extend your definition of
everyday physics to include you know why
the Sun shines for example ok we can put
the nuclear forces in there and you know
that's fine we need neutrinos to make
the Sun work etc but it's still within
the standard model of particle physics
and the claim here is that in terms of
that in that very very narrowly
prescribed area everyday physics we're
done we have discovered the fundamental
ingredients we're not going to find
anything new now of course we're going
to find new physics more broadly like we
don't know what the dark matter is right
we don't know why is a imbalance between
baryons and anti variance in the world
there's plenty of things we don't
understand we certainly don't have same
quantum gravity or the origin of the
universe or things like that physics is
not done but everyday physics has its
complete set of ingredients so I don't
even wanna say everyday physics is done
because the way those ingredients
combine is very complicated we don't
understand it right we don't understand
superconductivity for example there's
plenty about chemistry or biology that
we don't understand if you haven't
noticed right so I'm not saying that all
of those things are understood I'm
saying we know the ingredients are I'm
saying that whatever the explanation for
high-temperature superconductivity or
for biology turns out to be the origin
of life it will not involve ingredients
from fundamental physics over and above
the ones we've discussed here and the
reason why is because if there were new
articles and forces and quantum field
theory describes them and then we would
have discovered them so there's a
symmetry of quantum field theory called
crossing symmetry and I think that I
mentioned this in passing but maybe
didn't give it this name crossing
symmetry says if you have a Fineman
diagram describing some interaction
between particles and it has a certain
strength so let's imagine there is you
know here's an electron and this is an
electron you know in your brain okay
it's part of you part of your
consciousness right and someone says
well I think that there's another
particle called the X particle and it
interacts through some new force call it
the Y force with electrons and
understanding this new force is
crucially important to understanding
consciousness or the origin of life or
why tables are solid or something like
that okay yeah that's a perfectly
legitimate hypothesis you can think that
you can suggest it you could investigate
it but we have a Fineman diagram so we
can calculate the strength of this
interaction how likely is it that an X
particle will interact with an electron
and crossing symmetry says I can take
that diagram and I can rotate it by 90
degrees and I get another diagram which
has the same strength which is just as
noticeable as this diagram is and when I
do that rotation of course particles
become anti particles if they go from
one side of the diagram to the other so
this is saying that I could take an
electron and a positron a minus and E
Plus and I can smash them together to
make a y boson which will then decay
into two x bosons or an accident anti
expose on and we've done that this is
what we do is if a particle physicists
love the dus smash particles together
and look to see what comes out so we
have very strong constraints on where
particles are we know there are certain
kinds of particles you can imagine
existing that definitely don't exist so
there's no question to get if quantum
field theory is right quantum field
theory is not right all bets are off
but that was the presupposition of the
argument of course there are particles
and forces we haven't found yet but we
know that because we haven't found them
yet they're either particles that are
too massive to be created okay in
collisions like this up to Large Hadron
Collider scales or they are too weakly
interacting to be created and so this
diagram may be it exists but the actual
numbers attached to it are just
incredibly tiny or the particles just
decay away so fast that even if they're
made you don't notice that they were
made in any one of those cases there's
no way for this new particle and forests
had any impact on our everyday lives
unless your everyday life is that of a
theoretical or experimental physicist
okay and this fact - you know sometimes
I stated if you read my book the big
picture I go into this fact I try to
explain it I say the laws of physics
underlying everyday life are completely
known all the words in that sentence
matter okay its underlying everyday life
it's not of the emergent laws of higher
levels I'm not saying you understand
economics okay but I understand the
electrons and the nuclei that economists
are made out of and they're they're
completely known in the realm of
everyday life not in the realm of the
universe I'm not saying we know where
the universe came from I'm not saying
that physics is done I'm a physicist how
could I ever say that physics is done I
would do something different if I
thought the physics was done but the
laws of physics underlying everyday life
are completely known and this fact is
reflected in technological advances okay
now we sometimes think that you know
doing work in fundamental physics is
crucially important for technological
advances and it is but only because we
need technological advances to do
fundamental physics and therefore the
drive to do fundamental physics leads to
new technological breakthroughs but the
technological breakthroughs themselves
do not involve new fundamental physics
the last time new fundamental physics
new particles or forces turned out to be
relevant to technology was probably the
1950s you know the top quark in the
higgs-boson
these things are not things that affect
technology in any way because they you
need a billion-dollar accelerator to
take them and then they decay away in
ten to the minus twenty some seconds
okay and that's gonna continue to be
true there will be plenty of
technological advances but the
technological advances will consist of
clever ways of arranging these
ingredients electrons isotopes
electromagnetism and gravity and that
gives us constraints on what we can do
again if quantum field theory is correct
it means that you can't bend spoons with
your mind no I cannot bend this pencil
just by thinking about it other than
having my mind you know say that my arm
should go there and Bend it but there's
no way that a force can be extended from
my brain because the only forces that go
over large distances are
electromagnetism and gravity okay it
means that tractor beams will be
difficult to construct not necessarily
impossible but you'd have to do them out
of electromagnetism there's no new
forces shields and you can put up around
your spaceship to protect you from laser
beams well if you can do that with
electromagnetism that's great gravity is
too crude gravity is dumb right
electromagnetism maybe you can do it but
there's no other forces no other
particles that will be relevant to this
sorry about that but you know it's our
job here not only to discover cool new
things about the world but to face up to
them to accept what the world is
teaching us so there is both a frontier
of moving beyond everyday physics the
Big Bang quantum gravity Dark Matter etc
and there's another frontier of how
these ingredients come together to form
everyday physics logistical mechanics
chemistry biology psychology all that
stuff there's plenty more science to be
done but we should also kind of
recognize that some of the science we
wanted to do we actually have done